some really cool benefits
using ghee for your bulletproof coffee
now what's the main difference between
butter and ghee
it's mainly ghee is clarified butter so
basically they remove the milk solids
which includes casein which a lot of
people have allergies to
as well as lactose which a lot of people
are lactose intolerant so you get the
benefits of butter without the
issues that can mess up your digestive
system or give you an allergy now gea
has been around for a very very long
time it's used in various countries like
india for a lot of different
things cooking and health benefits and
if you're going to use bulletproof
coffee i would recommend using ghee
instead of regular butter especially if
you're lactose intolerant and to make
this really simple all you do is you add
one to two tablespoons of ghee
to a cup of coffee
blend it that's all you gotta do and i
would get the one that says a2 which is
a type of protein in a cow that is just
better for your digestive system now
another cool thing about ghee is it's a
pure fat and there's only really two
things that won't stimulate insulin one
is pure fiber and two is pure fat and of
course this is in addition to being on a
low carb diet
but protein can stimulate insulin carbs
will increase insulin but fiber and fat
will not so we get the benefits of
keeping your insulin low now let me just
go through uh really quickly some really
cool benefits of ghee in your coffee or
ghee just in your foods cooking with
ghee it has lutein which is a
type of carotenoid that's good for your
eye it can actually help prevent
something called macular degeneration as
we get older a lot of people get that
condition and then it affects their
vision so this can help avoid the
condition ghee also dramatically
decreases your appetite so it'll allow
you to fast longer so this is another
very powerful benefit because the longer
you can fast without food um the better
your health is going to be now the other
really cool thing about ghee is that it
has all of the fat soluble vitamins it
has vitamin a it has vitamin d it has
vitamin e
and vitamin k2 which is a very important
fat soluble vitamin to keep calcium in
the bone and out of the arteries and out
of the soft tissues like your joints and
also ghee has a digestibility ratio
or percentage of like 97 percent
compared to other fats that are not
digested as well
one interesting thing about ghee is that
it has a certain amount of
medium chain triglycerides called mct
fats and the unique thing about those
fats is they are not stored as fat
they're used as energy they turn into
ketones so they bypass the gallbladder
and the bile so they're much easier to
digest now the other thing about ghee is
that it has short chain fatty acids and
that's really good for gut health so if
you have inflammation in the gut
ghee would be very very beneficial ghee
also has something called cla which has
some really interesting properties it's
anti-carcinogenic
anti-inflammatory
it has an anti-allergy effect and the
last question
that a lot of people are going to want
to know about is
will consuming
this bulletproof coffee okay orgy
knock me out of ketosis okay let me just
clarify that well first of all it won't
knock you out of ketosis because it's
giving you ketones now is it going to
break your fast
well it's not going to increase insulin
okay uh it's a true fast is without food
okay so yes it can break your fast for a
little bit but as far as breaking your
ketosis state it's not going to do that
but it may slow down your weight loss if
you have a slow metabolism
but for most people starting out i do
recommend doing the bulletproof coffee
but the only time i wouldn't is let's
say your metabolism is very very slow
and you're doing everything to try to
speed up your weight loss then i would
not recommend adding any additional fats
that aren't normally in the food that
you would eat that comes with the
protein now i think a really interesting
video for you to watch next would be my
one on vitamin k2
check it out or put it right here